Ausreichend informiert in welcher Form? Also auf technischer Basis, denke ich, fühle ich mich ausreichend informiert, wovon diese Leute da denken zu sprechen. Ich sehe den aber an, dass sie nicht wissen, wovon die sprechen.
Wie ist es, Nübler und Andreas, wie ist es bei euch? Ihr gebt ja auch als Chaos Computer Club eine Menge Interviews zum Thema. Wie ist denn der Konsens in den Fragen? Gibt es immer wieder dieselben Geschichten, die angesprochen werden? Habt ihr das Gefühl, dass eine größere Sensibilität dafür vorherrscht oder interessiert es schlichtweg einen Haufen Leute einfach nicht?
Verschiedene Erfahrungen, die ich gemacht habe, ist, dass man durchaus mit vielen Leuten redet, die ein Verständnis dafür haben. Einige schaffen es in ihren Medien, das auch rüberzubringen. Andere liefern bloß das Schnittmaterial ab, das dann von irgendeiner Newsredaktion verwustet wird, wo die Aussagen dann wirklich nicht ankommen am anderen Ende. Und ich finde das Wort Propaganda hier wirklich nicht ganz unangebracht, weil die Diskussion völlig emotional und faktenfrei geführt wird.
Ein sehr polarisierendes Thema auch.
Ich wurde halt auch nur in den Medien transportiert und auch nur in so einen zerhackstückelten Propagandaschnipseln, die eben von irgendwelchen Redakteuren ausgesucht werden. Und da werden eben so eine Kernsätze dann immer wieder rausgeschnipselt und das läuft dann wirklich auf Propagandaremixes hinaus. Die Filter wirken nicht, die Filter wirken nicht, die Filter sind zu kurz. Also was soll der nächste politische Schritt sein? Dann gibt es eben ja die Packet-Inspection und längere Filter und chinesische Verhältnisse und irgendwie noch zehn Angestellte beim BKA mehr, weil die Liste wird ja immer länger. Und wo sonst soll sich da auch die Leistungsbemessung irgendwie durchsetzen als an der Liste, die immer länger wird, weil wenn die Liste kürzer werden würde, dann würden ja diese Angestellten am Ende irgendwie schlechte Arbeit leisten. Also muss die Liste immer länger werden, per Definition, per Selbstbegräts sozusagen. Das sind genau all diese Gefahren, die da mit geschaffen werden, per politischen Willen unter dem Emblem jetzt gerade Kinderpornografie. Nicht, dass man da wirklich andere Dinge gegen tun könnte. Wirkliche Leute mit die Sagaia schlusslich im Westen vor irgendwelchen belgischen Wohnungen mal die Türen eintreten ließe. Nein, jetzt werden hier irgendwelche DNS-Sperren integriert, implementiert.
Ja, wo du gerade Belgien sagtest, da gab es ja den Fall Dutou, wo also auch ein...
Ja, ich möchte da keine wirklichen Klischees ziehen, aber Belgien liegt einfach zu wie auf der Zunge.
Das war auf jeden Fall Klischee, aber wir halten uns fest.
Das ist aber ein prominentes Beispiel und das verdeutlicht auch ein Teil des Problems, dass nämlich die Leute, die tatsächlich Kindervergewaltigen, die solche Ringe betreiben, wo Kinder ins Land geschmuggelt, dann missbraucht und hinterher getötet werden, die gibt es wirklich, die gibt es da draußen und das sind teilweise auch hohe Politiker drin verwickelt. So, ich möchte mich jetzt hier nicht zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen, weil ich die Fakten lange nicht kenne, aber...
Du stehst schon ganz schön im Rahmen eigentlich.
Wo man mit Diamanten bezahlt, wo kriegt man Diamanten? Keine Ahnung, so eine Sachen kann man da durch die Hose.
Aber dann wird es unsachlich.
Das wird auf jeden Fall unsachlich. Wir rudern mal ganz schnell zurück und holen auch Andreas wieder vom Fensterbrett weg.
Ich sag nochmal Sachsen-Sumpf-Google und mehr sag ich nicht mehr.
Ja, also was ich eigentlich so der Kern nochmal, wo ich eigentlich ansetzen wollte, ist, ob an dieser Stelle überhaupt eine demokratische Entscheidung auf breiter Basis überhaupt möglich ist, aufgrund dieser doch sehr strengen technischen Tatsache des Kerns, um den es eigentlich geht.
Wahrscheinlich ist diese Diskussion um diese technische Tatsache, diese Internetsperren, wir haben es ja schon mal ganz kurz angesprochen, ist auch etwas, wo viele Leute sagen, wow, davon habe ich keine Ahnung, damit will ich auch nichts...
Genau, da ist wirklich die Gefahr, dass die Leute da eben wie immer abwinken, ach Computer, damit kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Davon habe ich keine Ahnung, damit will ich nichts zu tun haben und da werden sich schon genug Leute damit beschäftigt haben, damit es funktioniert.
Das wissen die Experten, die immer im Fernsehen sprechen.
Ach und Kinderporno, das betrifft mich ja gar nicht.
Genau, Kinderporno ist schlimm, das muss weg und deswegen ja. Und was dort tatsächlich hinter dieser eigentlichen, hinter diesem ja macht mal, steht, das ist eben aufgrund der technischen Komplexität überhaupt niemandem bewusst, dass man dort wieder, naja...
Also ich habe festgestellt, dass es durchaus so ein Generation Gap ist. Wenn man mit Leuten redet, die Internet benutzen, selbst wenn es in Anführungszeichen nur normale Benutzer sind, denen ist klar, dass man mal auf einen Link draufklickt, auf den man nie raufklicken wollte, dass das passiert. Und dass man dann, wenn man denen erklärt, naja, dann hast du morgen eine Hausdurchsuchung, dann gucken die auch. Also auch wenn man auch...
Ja, haben sie im schlimmsten Fall noch eine schlimme Rechnung gehabt, die sie stillschweigend bezahlt haben und heutzutage ist es dann gleich eine Hausdurchsuchung irgendwie.
Viel auf jeden Fall hast du hier einen sehr interessanten Aspekt mit in Diskussionen gebracht, nämlich dass die technische Art und Weise, wie die Argumente ausgetauscht werden, also die Argumente über den technischen Ablauf, viele Leute schlicht und ergreifend einfach abschreckt, sich damit zu beschäftigen. Vielleicht sollten sich da einige Stellen von Medien bis hin zu jedem von uns, der sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt, das auch mal auf die Nase schreiben, das möglichst einfach und möglichst simpel zu erklären, ohne sofort in technisches Fachgelaber auszuweichen, wo die Hälfte der Leute dann wieder sagt, boah, hab ich keine Ahnung von, versteh ich nicht. Vielleicht auch ein Ansatz, über den wir mal nachdenken können. Vielen Dank dir für den Anruf. 0331 70 97 110. Wir reden heute im Chaosradio auf Fritz über Internetsperren. Und ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, was ihr von diesem anstehenden Gesetz haltet, was hier auf uns zurollt. Wir hören kurz ein Stückchen Musik, danach geht's gleich weiter. Reality Detached von Forth im Chaosradio auf Fritz, Mittwochabend 0331 77 91 10. Wir reden über das geplante Gesetz zu den Sperren von bestimmten Seiten im Internet und ihr ruft an unter 0331, das habe ich eben schon mal gesagt, naja ihr wisst das schon. Der nächste am Telefon ist Björn, guten Abend Björn, ich grüße dich. Von wo rufst du an?
Ganz genau, der der letzte Mal auch schon da war. Jo, es geht mir um Folgendes. Es geht bei diesen Gesetze darum, quasi das Internet kaputt zu machen und Grundrechte einzuschränken. Und bevor die Technik klar ist, halten die auf der Pressekonferenz ein Schild hoch. Das ist doch Symbol oder finden Politiker sondergleich nicht. Wenn die Technik nicht steht, dann macht man doch keine Gedanken darüber, wie das Stoppschild am Ende aussieht.
Achso, du meinst jetzt, dass diese Website, die gesperrt sind, dass auf denen dann ein Stoppschild zu sehen ist, wie im Straßenverkehr, auf dem steht dann drauf zensiert.
Ja, das hatten sie ja in der Pressekonferenz.
In welcher anderen Form soll ein Internetausdrucker sonst so eine Seite hochhalten?
Kennt leicht nicht die Steigerung von Internetausdruckern?
Nee, da bin ich jetzt gespannt.
Das ist Internetausdrucker und wieder Einscanner. Ich hab neulich einen GIF gesehen von einer ausgedruckten und eingescannten Website.
Das ist schon ein bisschen älter, aber das ist wirklich großartig.
Es gibt auch Leute, die drucken E-Mails aus, um mir den Anhang zu zeigen, um mich zu fragen, was für eine Datei ist. So nach dem Motto, wird das funktionieren bei denen. Da stellt sich mir nur die Frage, das ist ja wohl kaum Politik, die sich nach irgendwelchen vernünftigen Idealen richtet. Wenn ich da noch von Geschichten wie die Synthen dazu höre, dass dann irgendwelche nekkischen Bilder der Synthen sensiert werden. Da wurde ja keiner bei Verletzt wird. Das ist doch reine Machtbulerei, wenn sich da die Politik mal weniger an ihren dummen Idealen, woher sie auch immer kommen mögen, und mehr an der goldene Regel orientieren würden.
Aber die Frage ist, was machen wir denn damit? Die Einsicht, dass unsere Politiker offensichtlich gerade wenig Ahnung haben von dem, was sie tun auf bestimmten Themenbereichen und relativ rücksichtslos in Fakten vorbei agieren. Wie gehen wir damit um als Gesellschaft? Was machen wir da?
Also eine Maßnahme von mir wäre, dass ich von allein mal ein paar nette Mails schreibe, wenn noch ein paar mitschreiben würden, und der dann schildere, dass ich deren Sperre innerhalb von 30 Sekunden umgehen könnte und diese 30 Sekunden meines Lebens nicht zurück bekomme, sodass die jetzt diese Mail lesen muss, dass sie dann 30 Sekunden ihres Lebens kosten wird. Wenn das genug sind, könnte man die Frau vielleicht mal zum Nachdenken anregen. Aber ich denke, wenn die vielleicht zur Einsicht kommen würde, dann gibt es den nächsten Doofen, der dann so ein Ungepasst haben will.
Das scheitert an der Realität, glaubst du? Sie liest ihre Mail selber?
Ja, das ist auch das Problem.
Und die Sache, sie hat ja selbst gesagt, dass es da diese 20 Prozent der Kinderschänder im Internet gibt, die das umgeben.
Wenn du weißt, wie man das umgeht, dann bist du ein Kinderschänder. Das ist irgendwie ihre Gedankenwelt dazu.
Ja, danke. Ich freue mich drüber, dass ich ein Kinderschänder bin. Ich bin eine gute Frau von allein. Was mich da interessieren würde, wenn ich sowieso schon ein Kinderschänder bin, wo ist denn dieses Stoppschild? Gibt es da schon eine IP-Adresse? Ich brauche eine neue Startseite.
Es gibt diverse Entwürfe im Netz. Mir fällt aber gerade keine Ohle ein. Kannst du suchen. Also es gibt auch diverse Verfälle. Bei der Titanic gibt es eine sehr schöne Version.
Die kenne ich auch eigentlich sonst.
Aber ich möchte gleich auf die richtige gehen.
Nee, die gibt es noch nicht. Die Provider haben gesagt, sie brauchen jetzt noch ein bisschen. Die Telekom hat gesagt, sie braucht sechs Monate. Das interpretiere ich mal als bis nach der nächsten Wahl. Ja, die Telekom hat sich sehr gewehrt.
Es hat nicht nur die Telekom, es haben sich einige Provider. In der letzten Sendung im Januar, als wir noch darüber gesprochen haben, war es ja noch so, dass das Ministerium mit den Providern reden wollte und sie dann davon überzeugen wollte, dass sie da mitmachen. Und nicht alle Provider fanden das cool, weil es auch hieß, die technische Umsetzung ist viel zu kompliziert und ist alles unglaublich teuer und eigentlich wären sie nicht dabei. Jetzt sind sie trotzdem alle im Boot. Was ist da passiert?
Daraufhin ist QSC aus dem Privatkundengeschäft ausgestiegen. Ob man das jetzt miteinander verknüpfen möchte oder nicht, sind wir dahingestellt. Aber es ist für die Provider zunehmend riskanter mit Privatpersonen mit Internet zu beliefern, weil man nicht weiß, was man da an Infrastruktur seinen Kunden in den Weg stellen muss.
Hatte ich vorhin schon erwähnt, der Herr Riesenhuber, der bei Kabel Deutschland und bei Vodafone eine sehr einflussreiche Position hat, ein Parteifreund der Frau von der Leyen ist. Ich denke, das hängt damit zusammen. Auch wenn man sich die Leute anguckt, dieses Betreiben scheint ein kleiner elitärer Zirkel zu sein. Man fragt sich immer, was der Wirtschaftsminister damit zu tun ist. Er hat ja den Gesetzesentwurf geschrieben und stellt dann fest, dass seine Frau, also die Chefin eines Adelige trinken Sekt und machen Benefits Vereins ist, der sich also dem Kampf gegen Kindesmissbrauch gewidmet hat, wo lauter Fonds drin sitzen. Und das sind die, die den Stein ins Rollen gebracht haben für diese Aktion, die also losgelaufen sind zum Innenminister und zu Frau von der Leyen und die maßgeblich daran beteiligt waren, überhaupt die politische Diskussion in Gang zu bringen.
Was man noch zu dem Thema sagen könnte, ist, dass es auf Netzpolitik.de einen sehr netten Artikel mit den sieben Lügen, der von der Frau von der Leyen gibt, der sehr lesenswert ist. Und zum anderen gibt es auf Wikileaks einen, ich weiß nicht, wie originalgetreuen Brief eines, einem aus dieser Kinderpornoszene, der beschreibt, was da passiert, um mal die andere Richtung zu sehen. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie authentisch das ist.
Also die angesichts der da doch drin befindlichen Verharmlosung des Missbrauchs von Kindern würde ich davon ausgehen, dass er authentisch ist. Also der beschäftigt sich in der Hälfte des Textes damit, sein Verhalten zu rechtfertigen. In der anderen Hälfte redet er darüber, wie die Szene aussieht. Ist ein bisschen eine sehr schmerzhafte Lektüre, aber ich halte den für authentisch.
Okay, also, Bjarne aus Hannover braucht auf jeden Fall eine neue Startseite und einen neuen Clown, denn den anderen hat er heute früh zum Frühstück schon verspeist. 03317797110. Der nächste Anruf kommt aus München. Servus nach München, guten Abend.
Ja, guten Abend, hallo.
Hallo, wie heißt du?
Walidom.
Hallo Walidom, was ist das für ein Name, der ist ja abgefahren.
Ja, ist nur ein Internet-Künstlername. Ich habe übrigens eine Startseite für den Vorredner.
Für Bjarne, ja?
Ja, das ist www.kinderpornos.info.
Also eine wunderschöne Seite mit einer richtig schönen Startseite vom Bundes-Sicherheitshauptamt.
Noch ein Clown zum Frühstück. Alles klar, lass mal zum Thema zurückkommen, Internet sperren.
Ich will mal zurückkommen, worauf ich hinwollte, es wurde sehr viel argumentiert in der Richtung, dass diese Sperren wirkungslos wären oder nicht hundertprozentig wirksam sind. Das halte ich für eine sehr gefährliche Debatte oder überhaupt das Argument zu nehmen. Aus dem Grund, weil es, ich bin Techniker, relativ mit vertretbarem Aufwand möglich ist, zumindest andere DNS-Server auszusperren. Das ist eine oder zwei Firewalls-Regeln, da werden mir die Leute vom CCC vielleicht zustimmen. Um zu sagen, du darfst nur diesen DNS-Server benutzen und keinen anderen. Das ist mit Sicherheit eine noch weiter gesteigerte Wirkung.
Ja und eine noch weiter aufgebaute Filterung. Das ist genau die Geschichte mit, dann haben wir chinesische Verhältnisse, weil dann komme ich und verkaufe VPN-Dienste und dann fängst du an VPN-Verkehr zu sperren.
Genau und sonst dreht sich die Spirale immer weiter. Kommt dann weiterhin dazu, denkbare Möglichkeit, wer das versucht zu umgehen, den Alleinschutt ist, schlafbar zu machen. Das ist also eine Sache, wo ich mich gar nicht darauf einlassen wollte, auf so eine Diskussion. Sondern ich will vielmehr auf eine grundsätzliche Diskussion hin, wo gesagt wird, okay, was ist denn der Vergleich Pressefreiheit und freier Informationszugang und alle diese Themen, die wir immer wieder ansprechen, im Vergleich. Und das ist jetzt wirklich böse und ich bin wirklich absolut gegen Kinderpornos und ihr habt mich schon im Netz gegen Kinderpornos und Hacker gegen Kinderpornos und wie sie alle heißen in 90ern, falls ihr euch erinnern könnt, schon engagiert und habt da viel gemacht. Aber jetzt wirklich mal auf einer grundsätzlichen Ebene, wenn ich den Missbrauch oder das Anschauen, nicht den Missbrauch selbst, sondern das Anschauen von solchem Material im Vergleich zu einer grundsätzlichen Infrastrukturstelle, mit der ich Sensor betreiben kann, wie beantworte ich die Frage, was ist hier wichtiger?
Das ist halt genau die Geschichte und deswegen muss man diese Argumentation mit der Wirksamkeit leider bringen. Du hast dann eine Abwägung von Grundrechten gegeneinander.
Das hatten wir ja eingangs schon mal.
Das hatten wir ja eingangs schon mal. Ich sage es gern nochmal, weil das ist der entscheidende Punkt in der Debatte. Es ist eine Grundrechtsabwägung und natürlich ist sozusagen die Einschränkung des Rechts auf Meinungs- und Informationsfreiheit viel einschneidender als etwas, was sowieso gar nicht wirksam ist. Also das ist einfacher, diesen Punkt zu machen. Wenn du die Wirksamkeit nicht betrachtest, hast du eine sehr viel, sehr viel schwierigere Diskussion zu rechtfertigen. Dann kommen die Leute wirklich und sagen irgendwie, ihr wollt doch aber bloß Kinderpornos gucken.
Alleine, dass wir uns die Frage stellen, dass wir uns eine Gelegenheit darüber machen, zeigt, dass irgendwo was versagt haben muss. Also dass da nicht nachgegangen wird, dass da nicht die Quellen bekämpft werden.
Das ist eigentlich die Richtung, wo wir auch hin sollten. Wir sollten sagen, warum werden die Quellen nicht bekämpft. Warum stellen wir fest, dass Schwedischen und Australischen kaum Kinderpornos sind, sondern Schwulenseiten und Lolita-Seiten, die nichts mit Kinderpornos zu tun haben, die nach deutschem Recht nicht strafbar sind. Dann zu sagen, lasst uns die Diskussion auf dieser Ebene führen und nicht dahin gehen, diese Wirksamkeit zu bezweifeln. Weil das heißt, man hat nur am Rückschluss, dass man sagt, dann machen wir es einfach wirksam, Merle.
Wenn du die Argumentation bringst, wirst du folgende Gegenargumentation bekommen. Das ist ja natürlich, tun wir schon alles für die Strafverfolgung, was wir können, aber wir müssen ja ganzheitlich eingreifen und wir müssen den Markt austrocknen und wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass die Nachfrage nicht da ist.
Okay, dann weißt du, genauso wie ich, dass die Nachfrage nach kommerziellen Angeboten nicht nachgewiesen ist, dass der kommerzielle Markt nicht vorhanden ist oder zumindest nicht nachgewiesen wurde an Studien. Heute hast du eine Studie auf dem Tisch gekriegt von einer IWF aus Großbritannien, die sagen oder haben halt relativ wenig kommerzielle Webseiten finden können und die, die wirklich kommerzielle Webseiten mit solchen Inhalten sind, seien in Ländern, in denen die Verfolgung relativ einfach möglich sein sollte. Das heißt, auch da ist nicht die Wirksamkeit, sondern die Sinnhaftigkeit einer Zensur nicht gegeben, weil man das einfach abschalten kann.
Lass uns das mal weitermachen, weil vielleicht kommen wir noch zu interessanten Punkten. Dann ist das nächste Argument, was du hören wirst, dass die Kinderpornos sozusagen eine Einstiegsdroge sind, dass also die Leute, die sich das angucken, irgendwann losgehen und tatsächlich Kinder vergewaltigen und wenn man sie davon fernhält, dann passiert vielleicht nicht so viel.
Also, ich bin jetzt kein Experte, und ich kenne mit dem AKS-Zensur, das ist jetzt so ein kleiner Kreis von Leuten, die sich dagegen engagieren, gibt es ein paar Leute, die vom Missbrauch, vom Kreis von Missbrauchspfand stammen. Die da wirklich mitarbeiten und selbst als Kind missbraucht worden sind und sich jetzt gegen diese Zensur wehren. Und die haben gesagt, die Leute aus ihrer Erfahrung, die Leute, die wirklich Kinder missbrauchen, haben eigentlich einen ganz anderen Hintergrund. Die haben ein Defizit an Kontroll, also ein psychologisches Problem mit erwachsenen Frauen zum Beispiel umzugehen.
Ich bin wie gesagt überhaupt kein Experte in dem Thema.
Nur, ich glaube einfach nicht daran, dass das eine Einstiegsdroge ist. Das könnte man weitertreiben, indem man sagt, jeder der sich Porno-Seiten ansieht und sich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, die Team-Pornos rein zieht, das wird ja über kurz oder lang auf Kinder-Pornos scharf sein. Das ist für mich keine Acht vor Unbelegten, das will ich mir mal zeigen.
Es erinnert sich ein bisschen an die Argumentationen der fundamentalen Christen in den USA, die sagen, wir müssen was gegen die schwule Propaganda tun, damit unsere Kinder nicht alle schwul werden.
Ja, genau das. Und das Nächste ist, das zu leisten mit Hut. Und das tut mir echt leid. Wir müssen alles gegen Kinder-Porno tun, im Rahmen, in der Verhältnismäßigkeit, aber in der Gesellschaft, dass leider bei den vielen Deppten, die bei uns rumlaufen, immer wieder vorkommen. Und die müssen wir festnageln, die müssen wir entsprechend behandeln, aber das komplett auszublenden, diese chinesische Schutzwand davor zu stellen, bringt gar nichts.
Okay.
Letzte Frage an dich nochmal, Walidom. Du hast ja am Anfang auch gesagt, du bist Techniker, kennst dich also mit den ganzen Maßnahmen auch aus und wir hatten vorhin ja schonmal die Meinung, dass die Diskussion um das Thema eigentlich schon auf einem sehr technischen Niveau geführt wird, wo viele Leute sagen, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf. Die Leute, die sich das ausgedacht haben, werden schon wissen, was sie da tun und ich winke das mal ab. Was glaubst du, wie man dagegen wirken kann, wie man eine größere Sensibilität für das Thema schaffen kann, um, wie Nibla vorhin so schön sagte, die zweite und die dritte Scheibe der Salami zu sehen, nicht nur die erste, wo die Schlagzeile draufsteht?
Einmal müssen wir es schaffen, die Medien auch mit den kritischen Argumenten ein bisschen zu bearbeiten. Da gibt es eine Pressematte vom Ackerzensur im Internet, einfach Google Ackerzensur, da gibt es eine Pressematte mit den sämtlichen Argumenten, die zusammengefasst sind. Das zweite ist, wir müssen im Internet vertreten sein, indem wir so Banner einbinden wie so ein Kinderpornos.info, da gibt es so ein Banner, wo draufsteht, morgen früh kommen die BKA-Leute mit Sturmgewehr im Anschlag in deine Bude gerannt, weil du diesen Banner nachgeladen hast von einer gesperrten Internetseite, um Leute im Siebel zu machen.
Den Leuten zu sagen, die jetzt sagen, ich habe nichts zu verbergen, denen mitzuteilen, doch du hast was zu verbergen.
Richtig. Genau, indem die Leute in die Realität holen. Und das dritte ist natürlich politische Aktionen, Herr Schäuble ist zum Beispiel am 7. Mai in Karlsruhe und spricht zum Thema Internetzensur oder Internetfilter und da kann man, ich wohne da nicht, aber wer da auch immer jetzt zuhört, da kann man hingehen und da mal ein Fähnchen hochhalten.
Zum Beispiel.
Oder andere Aktionen machen, wichtig ist, die Leute erreichen und ja, Revolution 2.0 gegen Stadio 2.0, ja.
Walidom, danke dir für den Anruf. Servus nach München. Ihr seid im Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über die geplanten Sperren im Internet, die Zensur von Webseiten. Der nächste Anruf kommt aus Paderborn von Patrick, guten Abend, Patrick. Grüß dich. Was hältst du davon, dass dieses Gesetz auf uns zurollt und dass demnächst Stoppschilder durchs Internet kursieren?
Ja, also zu der Wirkungslosigkeit kann man sich ja gerne noch streiten. Wie wir es ja vorhin schon gesagt haben, das kann mit 5W durchaus umgehen, aber es wird jeder unter einen Generalverdacht gestellt, was schon bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung eigentlich erfolgt.
Genau, die ist in der ganzen Diskussion doch, die Vorratsdatenspeicherung, eigentlich gar nicht mehr so auf. An die haben wir uns alle schon gewöhnt.
Richtig, genau und der Wiederruf, der beim Bundesgerichtshof läuft, ist ja noch lange nicht durch. Das ist ja der Generalverdacht, der dann da zukommt und der Kennzeichenabgleich von den ganzen Mautterminals, da lassen sich ja nicht nur die LKW-Kennzeichen abgleichen, sondern auch die PKW-Kennzeichen, durchaus, ohne Probleme. Und wir haben in Deutschland einen Zentralregister, das heißt wir können gucken, wem welches Auto gehört. Das ist ja natürlich auch alles möglich und machbar.
Also zum Glück weiß ich bei der Maut aus gewöhnlich gut unterrichteten Kreisen, dass die PKW-Kennzeichenerfassung da noch nicht an ist.
Noch nicht, aber das ist auch glaube ich kein großes Problem, die anzuschalten.
Die Jungs wollen das auch nicht, weil es ist mehr Aufwand beim Administrieren.
Wir wollen gar nicht weiterfragen, aber wie ist das, wenn ich einen kleinen Laster fahre, der jetzt noch kein 40 Tonner ist?
Der Punkt ist, wenn du mautpflichtig bist, fallen Daten an.
Solange mein Auto nicht sagt, ich bin mautpflichtig, ist alles cool.
Ja, solange du nicht mautpflichtig bist, ist alles cool. Wenn du mautpflichtig bist, wird dein Kennzeichen verarbeitet oder du hast so eine Box, die irgendwie sagt, wo du gerade bist. Und diese Daten werden vom Bunde, vom Zoll, genau der Zoll ist zuständig, die Aufsicht über die private Firma zu führen und nachzugucken, ob die Maut auch ordentlich abgerechnet wird. Und dazu brauchen sie natürlich eine Kopie aller Daten.
Wieder was gelernt. Danke Andreas vom CCC. So, aber zurück zu Patrick aus Paderborn.
Und ich finde, dass in den meisten Zeitungen auch sehr viel Propaganda gemacht wird. Also wenn man mal eine große Tageszeitung aus Berlin und eine Tageszeitung aus der Mitte Deutschlands vergleicht, kommt man zu dem Schluss, dass in der Tageszeitung aus Berlin wesentlich mehr drinsteht als aus der Mitte Deutschland.
Was glaubst du, woran liegt das?
Das liegt a. in der Ausrichtung der Zeitung, ganz klar. Und an dem, wie politischen Köpfe dahinterstehen. Weil in deiner Zeitung steht immer ein Verlag und damit auch eine gewisse politische Ausrichtung. Auch die Bildzeitung hat irgendeine Ausrichtung.
Ach, das wäre jetzt aber neu.
Ja, je nachdem, woher der Wind grad weht. Das ist das einzigste. Aber grad nur die Wildleser, die werden sich so, oh, Kinderporno, oh, ganz böse und, ne. Dann machen wir das doch. Und darauf ist es momentan ausgelegt. Weil so eine Sperre, naja, Wirksamkeit kann man halt bezweifeln oder eben auch nicht, ist halt da auf diesem Niveau leider ausgelegt.
Aber wo du kleine Zeitungen sagtest, das halte ich für einen ganz wichtigen Punkt. Ja, wir können auch als CCC ja nicht mit allen Journalisten in diesem Lande reden, sondern wir müssen uns immer auf die beschränken, die wir gerade in unserer Freizeit noch abgearbeitet bekommen. Wenn ihr irgendwo seid, wo es kleinere Zeitungen gibt, versucht mit denen an die Journalisten reinzukommen, versucht mit denen zu reden, versucht denen das Problem zu erklären.
Und versucht ihnen vor allem klar zu machen, dass sie direkt selbst davon betroffen sind.
Ja genau, sie können morgen nicht mehr recherchieren, wenn das durch ist. Das müssen die glaube ich mal verstehen. Und da habe ich eine gewisse Hoffnung. Und es gibt ja zum Glück auch noch Parteien, die zufällig gerade nicht an der Regierung sind und deswegen dagegen. Und wenn man sich die entsprechende Zeitung raussucht, dann bekommt man vielleicht auch so einen Artikel unter.
Also so wie ich das gesehen habe, in den Blogs steht dann halt meistens, oder wirkliche Blogs, nicht Twitter, stehen halt Informationen, die man, ja genau, die man halt sonst nicht so zu lesen kriegt. Also was da so geplant ist. Kinderporno ist wirklich nur der große Fleck. Und dahinter kommt noch viel, viel mehr. Die Leute, die Dinge festzumachen, wäre viel einfacher. Da haben wir das BKA für. Und dann kann das die Leute auch gegebenenfalls festnehmen. Die haben doch jetzt irgendwo den Ungarn-Server hochgenommen. Irgendwie mit Rails-Daten. Warum geht das nicht mit Kinderpornografie? Das geht bestimmt auch. Nur das ist ein Aufwand, den die nicht treiben wollen. Da sagen die los, wir packen ein Label drauf, und dann ist Kinderporno erst mal zu. Zumindest für den nicht geschuldenen User.
Und stattdessen finden dann so Dinge wie Operation Himmel statt, wo mal eine breite Masse an Leuten beschuldigt wurde? Gab es da irgendwie ein einziges Verfahren?
Ich glaube, es gab ein paar Selbstmorde von Leuten, die beschuldigt waren, es aber gar nicht waren, weil ihre Kreditkartendaten geklaut waren.
Das waren die, wo über 12.000 Daten überprüft wurden?
Genau, die Rasterfahndung.
Das war das vor 2 Jahren etwa, oder 1, 5 Jahren?
Von übrigens dem einzigen Staatsanwalt in Deutschland, der sich um das Thema Kinderpornografie kümmert, der sitzt in Halle.
Ja, und was ich noch glaube, wir schaffen uns jetzt ein neues Feindbild. Osama bin Laden, soll er tot sein, also brauchen wir ein neues Feindbild.
Polemikmodus wieder aus.
Ja, ich weiß. Ich denke mal als Hintergrund, weil der Innenminister wird da bestimmt auch ein großes Interesse daran haben, dass es so einen Filter geben wird.
Es haben eine ganze Menge Leute ein Interesse daran. Wir haben es ja vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt, es gibt Interesse vom Bildungsministerium, die sich Gewaltseiten wegsperren wollen, was auch immer das jetzt im Speziellen ist, ob es jetzt Killerspiele sind oder sonst was. Es gibt Interesse von der Musikindustrie, es gibt Interesse von der Filmindustrie, es gibt Interesse von Softwareherstellern, um Torrent-Tracker und alles andere zu machen. Und dann geht es natürlich hin von religiösen, antireligiösen, politischen Webseiten, wo auch immer irgendeine Befindlichkeit ist, von einer höheren Stelle, die sagt, das möchte ich bitte nicht der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich machen. Und dann sind wir an dem Punkt, an dem diese Internetsperren unter anderem auch eingreifen könnten. Und deswegen machen wir heute diese Sendung an dieser Stelle.
Ich denke mal, dass wir irgendwann, wenn wir das jetzt alles so weiterspinnen, bei chinesischen Verhältnissen landen. Und zwar noch viel schlimmer als das, was die momentan da haben, dass es dagegen noch harmlos ist. Und dann werden wir ohne Religion und Nation nicht mehr ins Internets kommen.
Deswegen ist es immer noch wichtig, mit den Leuten zu reden, mit eurer lokalen Zeitung zu reden, mit den Leuten um euch herumzureden, in der Klasse oder wo auch immer, auf Arbeit oder in der Uni, um einfach Argumente auszutauschen, um ein Interesse dafür zu schaffen. Weil sonst sagen alle Leute, oh Computer ey, kenn ihr mich sowieso nicht aus, wird schon irgendwie funktionieren. Patrick, danke dir für den Anruf.
Alles klar, tschüss.
Wir machen jetzt gleich Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und danach geht es weiter hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz mit euch 0331 70 97 110. Was wird uns da gerade eigentlich als Internetsperre verkauft und wie geht ihr damit um?
Mitten im Sommer bringt euch Fritz Clueso, Selig, Klee, Tele, Super 700 und Mia. Am 10.07. Fritz im Freim. Die Fritz Open Airs. Solang es doch Karten und Kombi-Tickets gibt, gibt es Karten und Kombi-Tickets überall, wo es Karten und Kombi-Tickets gibt. Und mehr Infos. Fritz die. Fritz im Freim. Die Fritz Open Airs in der Zitadelle Spandau. Einmal im Juli und einmal im August, aber immer im Freien. Und das hört man.
2,512. Mitkeit natürlich.
Die Weltgesundheitsorganisation WAO warnt immer deutlich vor einer möglichen Pandemie der Schweinegrippe. Sie hat das Risiko auf die zweithöchste Stufe 5 angehoben. Der Gesundheitszustand der drei deutschen Schweinegrippe-Patienten aus Hamburg und Bayern hat sich nach Angaben der zuständigen Gesundheitsbehörden inzwischen deutlich gebessert. Alle drei waren zuvor in Mexiko gewesen, wo die meisten Fälle der neuen Grippe registriert werden. Bundesaußenminister Steinmeier hat den jüngsten Anschlag auf die Bundeswehr in Afghanistan als feige und heimtückisch verurteilt. Bei dem Angriff war am Abend ein deutscher Soldat getötet und vier verletzt worden. Es war bereits der zweite Anschlag des Tages auf die Bundeswehr. Schon am Morgen waren fünf deutsche Soldaten bei einem Selbstmordantentat nalkundlos verletzt worden. Berlins Datenschutzbeauftragter Dix hat junge Leute davor gewarnt, zu viele persönliche Infos ins Internet zu stellen. Besonders bei sozialen Netzwerken wie Facebook oder StudiVZ rät er zur Vorsicht. Nutzer sollten nicht ungeschützt private Daten und Bilder online stellen. Das würde den Datenmissbrauch erleichtern. In der Fußball-Champions-League kann sich der englische Verein Manchester United Hoffnung machen, den Titel zu verteidigen. Im Halbfinale-Hinspiel schlug die Mannschaft Arsenal London 1 zu 0. Das Rückspiel wird am kommenden Dienstag in London ausgetragen. Hier sind noch die aktuellen Temperaturen. In Cottbus haben wir 11 Grad, Neuropin und Angermünde 12, Potsdam-Wittenberge 13, Frankfurt 14 und in Berlin Werte zwischen 14 und 15 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenige Wolken und es ist deshalb auch meistens trocken. Die Temperaturen gehen runter bis auf 6 Grad. Morgen startet der Tag sonnig, aber dann später, besonders an der Elbe, gibt es auch mal ein bisschen Regen und vereinzelt auch Gewitter. Es bleibt aber sonst trocken bei bis zu 25 Grad. Und wir haben gleich drei Meldungen von der A10. Einmal vom westlichen Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Haffeland zwischen Potsdam Nord und Spandau. Da liegt ein totes Wildschwein auf der Fahrbahn. Bitte vorsichtig fahren. A10, nördlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Haffeland zwischen Birkenwerder und Kreuz Oranienburg. Dort liegt ein toter Fuchs auf der Fahrbahn. Und am östlichen Berliner Ring, auf der A10, Richtung Dreieck-Schwanenbeck zwischen Marzahn und Hohenschönhausen. Dort gibt es Gefahr durch einen defekten Tanklastzug. Dort ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Und noch eine letzte Meldung von der A15, Dreieck-Spraywald Richtung Übergang Forst zwischen Rogghausen und Forst. Da hat ein Auto gebrannt. Dort gibt es jetzt Behinderung. Und der Verkehr wird einspurig vorbeigeleitet. Euch eine gute Fahrt.
Kai Tandürlich mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr, 5 nach halb 12.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn im Radio 89, 85, dann Fritz im Berliner Kabel.
Bortes vom Taucher, Chaosradio auf Fritz, Nibla ist hier und Andreas ist da vom CCC. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über die angedachte oder schon als Gesetzentwurf vorliegende Planung, Webseiten im Netz zu sperren. Haben jetzt ganz viele Meinungen gehört, die sich dagegen stellen. Jetzt kommt eine Meinung pro und zwar von Chris aus Reinickendorf. Na, Chris? Grüß dich. Wieso bist du dafür?
Weil ich zweifacher Vater bin und daher werde ich das für, ja, positiv werden. Und wie ist es viel zu lush? Also ich meine, ich habe jetzt öfters die Nachrichten verfolgt und da ist es auf einmal, ja, wir brauchen noch ein halbes Jahr, bis alles umgeändert werden kann, wo ich dann auch schon wieder denke, so wir tun das Volk erstmal beruhigen, dass da was passiert, aber naja.
Wie siehst du denn die Seite der Kritiker, die sagen, es geht hier eigentlich gar nicht um die Eindämmung von Kinderpornografie, die ja sowieso schon unter Strafe steht und die viel einfacher zu bekämpfen wäre, sondern es geht eigentlich darum, langfristig eine Zensur im Internet einzuführen?
Na ja, scheiße. Also ich finde, die Leute, die meinen, es ist nicht so schlimm, die haben echt eine Klatsche, weil ich finde, so was überhaupt auf so eine Seite reinzugehen und auf Kinder zu stehen, ist echt Schwanz ab- und wegsperren. So lebenslänglich wegsperren, weil das kann nicht sein. Ich meine, jeder war Kind und wieso muss man, nur weil man aus einem zerrütteten Familienhaus oder eine schlechte Kindheit hat oder missbraucht wurde, das anderen Menschen antun. Also das ist zwar echt krank, natürlich ist es krank, aber wenn es nach mir geht, Todesstrafe, Schwanz ab-
Aber dir ist schon klar, dass diese Maßnahmen, die beschlossen werden, nicht dagegen helfen, dass deswegen kein Kind weniger verarbeitet wird.
Ich weiß, deswegen sollte man auch das Strafmaß erhöhen und nicht gleich, wenn es heißt, dass ein Psychologe sagt, er ist geheilt und trotzdem wieder die gleiche Scheiße baut. Das ist einfach scheiße, das System von der Justwiz in dem Punkt.
Aber es hat ja dann in dem Fall wenig zu tun mit den geplanten Sperrungen von Webseiten.
Wie gesagt, ich finde gut, dass es gemacht wird, nur es dauert mir zu lange, weil auf einmal heißt es, es dauert noch ein halbes Jahr, bis verschiedene Leute es schaffen, es umzusetzen.
Ich finde es also gut, dass die Energie darauf verschwendet wird, einen Fehler zu implementieren und nicht darauf, die Leute anzugehen, die mit so was handeln.
Also ich finde gut, dass es passiert und ich finde nicht gut, dass die Leute nicht an, also dass nicht auf die Leute zugegangen wird und gleich gesagt wird, hier komm, pack dir die Handschellen um und Tschüss.
Aber kannst du erklären, was du daran gut findest, nachdem wir festgestellt haben, es wird nicht helfen?
Es wird, also ich finde schon, dass es helfen wird, weil dann hat nicht mehr jeder die Möglichkeit. Natürlich werden sich irgendwelche Tunnels bauen, um irgendwie anders an so eine Seite ranzukommen, aber es ist erst mal ein Fortschritt. Andere vielleicht nicht, aber ich sehe es so.
Also dadurch, dass so Seiten ausgeblendet werden aus dem Internet, dadurch, dass man das nicht mehr wahrnimmt, dass da ein Problem besteht, dass da Leute austauschen, findest du, dass den Kindern geholfen wird?
Den Kindern wird noch nicht wirklich dadurch geholfen, aber es wird erst mal im Internet weggeschlossen.
Es wird ja nicht weggeschlossen, das ist ja das Punkt, aber es ist nicht weg.
Ganz im Gegenteil, man macht da die Augen zu und sagt, okay, die Seiten gehen uns jetzt nichts mehr an, das Problem anzugehen. Steht unter Strafe, aber was dagegen zu tun...
Man kann sie ja tatsächlich wegkriegen, indem man zu dem Rechner läuft, wo sie draufliegt, den mitnimmt und den Typen dann betreibt gleich auch mit.
Das ist ja eigentlich das Thema der heutigen Sendung, dass es eigentlich darum geht, dass solche Rechner oder solche Straftaten viel effektiver und viel schneller zu bekämpfen sind und viel schneller zu finden sind, weil ein Großteil der Rechner steht in Westeuropa, das ist erwiesen, und dann kann man relativ einfach den Provider entweder anschreiben oder gleich die Strafvermittlungsbehörden einschalten und dann sagen, da und da steht der und der Server und dann geht das relativ schnell. Deswegen ist dieses Instrument, was hier gerade installiert wird, und das ist ja das Thema der heutigen Sendung, die schön vom Nibbler gezitierte dritte Salamischeibe, es geht ja eigentlich um was ganz anderes und darüber wollen wir heute reden. Aber nochmal zurück zum Anfang, auch die anderen Leute haben ja gefragt, fühlst du dich in Ergänze über dieses Thema gut unterrichtet? Hast du das Gefühl, du hast da Durchblick und weißt, was da für ein Gesetz auf dich zukommt?
Es wurde nur gesagt, es werden jetzt Internetseiten, was darauf hinweist, dass es eine Pornografieseite ist, gesperrt. Aber es wurde noch nicht so viel berichtet, dass man daraus schlau wird. Es wurde einfach nur in den Raum geworfen, dass pornografische Seiten, die kinderpornografische Inhalte haben, gesperrt werden. Es ist einfach sowas in den Nachrichten gebracht. Und da lachte ich mir so, ist ja geil, wenigstens mal was. Es wird nicht irgendwelche Missbrauche davon verhindert, was auch scheiße ist.
Also das Gefühl hab ich halt auch bei dieser Maßnahme, dass es bloß darum geht, so zu demonstrieren, wir tun ja was. Also es geht eigentlich eher um den Showwert für die Politiker.
Die Politik steht dann erstmal wieder gut da. Irgendwo auf einer Seite.
Also ich meine, ich teile ja deine moralische Entrüstung darüber, was Kindern angetan wird. Aber genau auf der Welle schwimmt das ja. Und dann guckt man nicht mehr so genau hin. Das ist halt das Problem, das wir da haben.
Man sollte einfach mehr dafür tun. Man sollte einfach gucken, was die Kinder... Also man sollte seine eigenen Kinder einfach mehr begleiten und nicht überall mehr hingehen lassen, weil die meisten Eltern einfach ja Augen zu, hier hast du Geld und durch.
Ich finde wichtig ist auch nicht weggucken. Viele Missbrauchsfälle, die bekannt geworden sind, da haben schon irgendwie Leute so ein bisschen was mitbekommen. Aber keiner wollte das wahrhaben.
Weil sie einfach wussten, was auf sie zukommt, wenn sie es mitbekommen. Ich finde es einfach scheiße.
So fehlende Anteilnahme, so Desinteresse, dann wird es alles kompliziert. Und Polizei und so und der Nachbar ist ja eigentlich gelassen.
In Deutschland sind die zu 100% oder zu 80% die meisten Deutschen Augen zu und durch. Ich habe nichts gesehen, ich weiß von nichts, lasse mich in Ruhe.
Beziehungsweise es interessiert mich nicht, es ist mir zu kompliziert.
Und das finde ich so asozial. Das heißt doch immer, weiß ich nicht, es wird doch schon so viel Promoganda gemacht, von wegen Schauten, mach dies, mach das.
Und das ist genau das, was diese Internet-Twitter eben nicht macht, das Wegschauen. Das habe ich verstanden.
Ist ja vollkommen okay. Ich meine, deswegen ist ja auch eine Sendung wie diese und viele andere da und viele Weblogs, die sich genau mit dem Thema beschäftigen, um ein bisschen dahinter zu gucken und zu erklären, worum es da eigentlich geht.
Was ich halt gut fand, von einem von meinen Vorsprechern, von wegen hier mit diesen auf der Internetseite Hinweise, so du bist jetzt darauf gegangen, morgen steht das BKA vor deiner Haustür und nimmt dich mit. Find ich gut. Sollte man vielleicht auch.
Alles klar. Chris, danke dir für deinen Anruf und gute Nacht noch. 0331 70 97 110. Wir geben die Frage, wie informiert, führt er euch eigentlich über das Thema, oder geht er mal weiter nach Köln zu Mark? Guten Abend, Mark.
Schönen guten Abend.
Bist du im Thema drin, oder hast du auch nur die Schlagzeilen? Unsere Arzttechnik interessiert mich nicht.
Absolut im Thema drin. Mich hat dann, das war letzte Woche, auf heise.de irgendwo der Schlag getroffen, da hab ich gelesen, dass die eine Live-Überwachung wollten. Das hat dann ziemlich stark meine Interesse auf sich gezogen und hab dann halt mal ein bisschen die Threads verfolgt und mehr als zuvor bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gekotzt. Letzten Endes, es wird rhetorisch von der Frau von der Leyen doch recht interessant und gut verkauft. Und sehr stark, wie ihr auch gesagt habt, emotional besetzt. Natürlich ist das ein Totschlagargument und mit dem Argument Kinderpornografie kann man einen sehr starken Hebel ansetzen, um Überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten. Aber das Problem, was ich hauptsächlich sehe, ist eigentlich, wie schafft man es den Leuten, die keinen Bock auf Fachbegriffe haben aus dem Technikbereich, zu den Leuten durchzudringen. Und ja, nicht, dass hier eine Aktion gestartet wird, da eine Aktion gestartet wird, sondern dass den Leuten klargemacht wird. Ja, wir haben eine Geschichte in Deutschland, eine Gewaltenteilung macht Sinn. Und dass hier alles jetzt nun beim BKA in einer Instanz verinnerlicht ist, dass ich noch nicht mal nachprüfen dürfte.
Weil die Liste nicht offiziell ist?
Richtig und das heißt ja auch, dass ich nicht nachprüfen dürfte, recherchieren dürfte, auch wenn ich Anwalt oder Journalist bin, ob das Ganze denn nur rechtmäßig war. Und das Fehler passieren sah man in Finnland, als das W3C, also dieses World Wide Web Konsortium, letztes Jahr im September gespeuert wurde. Also Fehler passieren, wo Menschen dran sind, das ist normal. Das ist mit wirtschaftlichen Schäden. Natürlich frage ich mich, was kann ich machen? Also ich kotze, um es auf den Punkt zu bringen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das hier legitim ist, diese Wörter im Radio zu gebrauchen.
Markus Köln spricht jetzt Wörter.
Entschuldigung, ich versuche mich zu Maßregeln. Ja, was kann man machen? Ich habe gesagt, Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat hier nicht viel zu suchen. Ich stimme zu, ist auch nur ein kleiner Bestandteil davon, weil BKA speicherte nicht, das wird ja beim Internet Service Provider gemacht.
Genau, aber die Entwicklung ist schon interessant, dass erst die Vorratsdatenspeicherung kam und jetzt geht es weiter. Die kleinen Puzzle-Steine bauen sich so zusammen, ne?
Absolut richtig. Das einzig interessante ist bei der Frage, was kann ich tun, kann man nur empfehlen, weil das Wort auch so einfach ist, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die da gibt es eine Liste von Sachen, die man machen kann. Ich habe meinem Abgeordneten oder meiner Abgeordneten hier auch schon geschrieben. Lustigerweise, ich bin nicht der Erste gewesen, ist immer noch unbeantwortet. Aber interessanterweise, wenn man da ein bisschen weiter schaut auf diese Abgeordneten-Watch-Seite, sieht man, da scheint wirklich ein paar Leute zu interessieren. Bis dato habe ich es immer nur auf irgendwelchen privaten Foren gesehen. Glücklicherweise bei Spiegel Online haben sie vom Heiseforum einen Artikel eins zu eins übernommen. Und ich denke mal, das könnte der erste Schritt sein. Man sieht dann auch in den Mediatheken vom ZDF-3-Satz auch ein paar Statements.
Genau, der richtige Punkt ist schon, du hast es dann bei heise.de und im Forum von dem Portal gelesen.
Das darf nicht geek bleiben, das muss die Leute erreichen.
Ja, und das ist aber total geek, weil es erreicht eben relativ wenig Leute. Es gibt dann morgen wieder in der Zeitung eine riesen Schlagzeile und vielleicht zwei O-Töne aus einer Pressekonferenz rausgeschnitten und damit ist das Ding breit getreten. Und wir, glaube ich, nähern uns in den letzten zwei Stunden genau dem Problem so genähert, dass viel zu wenig darüber bekannt wird, was da eigentlich passiert. Nibler, mir gefällt immer noch das Bild mit der Salamischelbe, die du gebracht hast.
Ja, oder was ich auch gelesen habe, sehr treffend, finde ich, eine Seite aus dem Telefonbuch rausreißen und glauben, dass die Nummer nicht mehr da ist. Also das ist ein Schwachsinn. Na ja, gut, auf jeden Fall, und wie man das Ganze halt bündeln kann letzten Endes. Und die Möglichkeiten des Einzelnen sind sicher limitiert, aber letzten Endes, man hat einen Computer, wenn man sich aufregt und dann kann man eben Redaktionen schreiben, dann kann man seine Abgeordneten fragen und danach haken, das sind einmal die Sachen. Man kann im Privatkreis, im Bekanntenkreis, wo man da nicht automatisch den Stempel aufgedrückt bekommt, aha, du bist also einer, der dafür bist. Und dass man also da schon mal die richtige Bühne hat und nicht gleich abgestempelt wird, muss man sich halt die Zeit nehmen und den Leuten das erklären, um was es da eigentlich geht. Und dass die ersten Begehrlichkeiten auch schon geweckt sind und dass das der erste Anfang ist, letzten Endes. Und ja, dass hier ein Teil von Rechtsstaatlichkeit doch irgendwo gerade ziemlich billig verkauft wird.
Da waren ganz, ganz viele schlaue Sachen dabei, was du gesagt hast, Mark. Und ich fand überhaupt keine schlimmen Wörter.
Ja, ich hab mich auf Maß geregelt.
Eine andere Frage an Andreas von Nibbler, weil Mark hat es gerade ganz schön angesprochen, dass man was tun kann. Wie groß ist denn momentanes Arbeitsaufkommen beim Chaos Computer Club zu dem Thema? Wie viele Anfragen kriegt ihr denn pro Tag? Weil natürlich werdet ihr auch als Experten rangezogen, zum Interviews geben, Pressemeldungen schreiben und so.
Also, wenn das Thema gerade aktuell ist, werden wir ziemlich überschwemmt. Dann kommen da so viele Anfragen rein, dass wir teilweise nicht mehr antworten können und sagen, ne, das wird leider nichts mehr mit dem Interview heute.
Das Problem ist halt, dass sich das auch in eher zwei Lager aufteilt. Zum einen der, ich nenne sie jetzt mal, Qualitätsjournalismus, aber naja, was man auch immer darunter verstehen will. Also Leute, die wirklich weiter denken, so das betrifft mich selbst als Journalisten, die das Thema versuchen, einfach dann darzustellen, weil es eben da diese Polarisierung gibt, weil es relativ einfach zu sagen ist, oh, gegen Kinderpornos ist toll. Und dann auf der anderen Seite natürlich eben die Leute, die eine Schlagzeile machen wollen, die sagen wollen, Kinderpornos, schreiben wir mal zwei, drei Sätze drüber und das wars dann. Aber die Komplexität des Themas, das Problem nicht rüberbringen können, ob der Komplexität.
Das Schlimme ist ja auch, ich bin bei der Suche und beim Surfen links und rechts auch über ein PDF-Dokument gestoßen, das letztendlich ein Gutachten ist, dass von Sachverständigen der Regierung, von der Regierung beauftragt, zur Verfügung gestellt wurde. Und das Fazit war letzten Endes, genau das, was der T9, die sind natürlich wie nicht anders zu erwarten, auch natürlich jetzt im Gremium des Chaos Computer Clubs, ist einfach, dass hier grundgesetzbezogen doch einige Bedenken zu äußern sind, dass die Wirksamkeit letzten Endes ein Witz ist. Und ich möchte mich gar nicht mit anderen DNS-Servern groß befassen. Ich möchte mich nicht mit irgendwelchen VPN-Tunneln befassen, weil letzten Endes damit ich schon akzeptiere, dass es so kommen wird und einfach nur quasi mit dem Fügel und dem Weg um das Problem herumsuche. Und ich sage halt Leute, das geht so nicht.
Lustig fand ich, was Frau von der Leyen zu diesem Gutachten gesagt hat. Sie hielt nämlich ein anderes Gutachten daneben und meinte, das ist viel dicker als dieses Dürre-Gutachten. Und deswegen ist das dicke Gutachten besser unterdrückt. Wirklich.
Ja, ein Donald Duck Buch ist auch dicker als das Grundgesetz.
Richtig. Marc, das ist ein großartiges Schlusswort gewesen. Danke dir.
Ich wünsche euch einen schönen Abend.
Nibler, wir müssen ja was noch ganz anderes machen. Du hast eine Musik mitgebracht. Was hören wir denn jetzt gleich?
Wir haben noch den Wetter voller Musik, oder?
Lass uns doch kurz in die Musik reinhören und dann machen wir den Wetter frosch. Oh, die CCC-Leute reden schräges Zeug. Lasst euch überraschen, was gleich passiert. Nebelarbeit ist es für eine Platte.
Das ist BZ da mit Kletzmer.
Ein Bild für Götter, zwei vor.
Und dazu begrüßen wir den Wetterforscher am Telefon. Wir haben da so eine Veranstaltung in Köln, habe ich gehört, und du organisierst die, erzähl doch mal ein bisschen.
Ich mache da auch ein bisschen mit. Genau, wir haben in Köln die SIGINT 09, Signal Interrupt, das ist von 22. bis 24. Mai in drei Wochen. Im Kölner Komet ist ein schickes Medienzentrum, direkt im Medienpark in der Innenstadt. Und da steht für Signal Intelligence, wie für Signal Interrupt, sind so die Assoziationen, die am Norden da kommen können. Es geht darum, Zeichen zu setzen, Signale für die Gesellschaft auch zu setzen, die sich mit Informationstechniken und dessen Folgen für die Gesellschaft und dessen Anwendungen in der Gesellschaft, die uns vielleicht eher so ein bisschen verborgen bleiben, beschäftigen. Also zum Beispiel, wie für Andreas auch, etwas über Signal Intelligence, also Geheimnistätigkeiten selbst gemacht, referieren, aber auch das ganze Thema der Internetzensur wird bei uns in vielen Veranstaltungen zur Sprache kommen.
Vielleicht muss man es noch dazu sagen, wir machen ja jedes Jahr den Chaos Communication Congress und das ist mittlerweile eine sehr internationale und vor allen Dingen auch sehr technische Veranstaltung geworden. Wir wollten die SIGINT, also eigentlich eher, die richtet sich an Publikum aus dem Land, also insbesondere an Journalisten und hat halt auch die Politik im Vordergrund. Also die Dinge, über die wir gerade geredet haben, mal am Stück Leuten vorzutragen.
Genau, wir sagen auch, dass die erste Veranstaltung, die sich jetzt nicht direkt speziell an die Hacker-Community oder Szene wendet, sondern eben an die Öffentlichkeit sich richtet und von uns gemacht wird und wo wir auch verschiedenste Projekte und Gruppen aus unserem Umfeld vorstellen wollen oder die Möglichkeit geben wollen, sich zu präsentieren. Und an der Stelle auch nochmal eingeladen, bin sympathisierende Gruppen aus unserem Umfeld und sich denken, oh, politische Themen innerhalb des CCCs werden mal diskutiert. So ein paar Plätze haben wir vielleicht noch für Stände oder einen Workshop.
Kann ich da auch als Autonormalverbraucher vorbeikommen?
Da kann man einfach vorbeikommen, geht drei Tage, kostet normal 60 Euro für Schüler 40 Euro.
Dann sag doch nochmal ganz schnell die Eckdaten bitte. Wann, Wo, Wie und Ohl.
22. bis 24. Mai in Köln, in der Innenstadt im Kölner Komet, SIGINTCCCDE, SIGINTCCCDE und alle möglichen Themen, die der Club eben zu bieten hat gesellschaftlicher Naturwände, präsentiert Datenschutz, Informationsfreiheit, Wikileaks, offene Regierungen oder irgendwie auch die ganze Urheberrechtsfrage, werden wir uns allen widmen und haben da auch eine freundliche Unterstützung von der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung, das sollt ich vielleicht an der Stelle noch sagen.
Es gibt ja auch in diesen Tagen die ganze Menge zu diskutieren, deswegen euch viel Spaß an Köln. Danke dir, tschüss. Und danke euch auch fürs Zuhören in diesem Chaosradio Nr. 145. Noch mal hören geht selbstverständlich entweder auf fritz.de im Podcast oder aber auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Das nächste Chaosradio gibt es dann Ende Mai dann mit dem Kollegen Markus Richter, weil ich da Norwegen unsicher machen werde. Und wir hören uns dann im Juni wieder. Andreas und Nibbler, danke, dass ihr hier wart und kommt alle gut nach Hause. Vielen Dank.